Hi, in this video we'll take a look at how you can configure Burp Suite Enterprise to support
single sign-on over LDAP so your users can log in with their existing Active Directory credentials.
First log into your Burp Suite Enterprise server as an administrator. Go to the settings menu and
choose integrations. On the LDAP tile click configure. Under connection details select LDAP or LDAP S. We
recommend using LDAP S whenever possible. In the server field enter the IP address or host name of
your Active Directory server. The port will update automatically so by default 389 for LDAP and 636 for LDAP S.
Under service account details enter the username and password for a valid Active Directory service
account. This will be used to query your Active Directory when authenticating users.
Specify the base distinguished name from which Burp Suite Enterprise should search for users. All the users you want to manage must be children of this base DN.
Select a login method to determine whether users log in with their user principal name or their SAM account name.
Select a login method to enter the IP address. Once you're happy with your entries click check connection. If your server uses a self-signed certificate for LDAP S
upload the root certificate when prompted if necessary. Then once the connection is established you can create your user groups and configure their permissions.
Select a login method to enter the IP address. Once you're happy with your user group.